yeah so it's really funny when i think
oh man
when i tweeted my current thoughts
yesterday that
the media would call it for biden trump
would win in the courts and then claim
he stole the election
point being that if the media claims joe
biden wins but trump's
trump actually wins they'll say but i
don't understand i saw an msnbc that
that joe biden won trump stole it
he stole it from us he stole it from us
that stupid fat herbert
well trouble the orange orc he's
actually
giant yeah he's huge he's very long so
uh
the the the best example is that this
guy i know known for a long time
response so so uh vosh we had on the
show tweets at me he's like oh tim
the media doesn't call elections it's
like wow
to imagine like uh and and with respect
for for to him for coming on the show
and everything but imagine
sitting through an election watching the
media be like we're calling
louisiana for trump we're calling new
york for joe biden and then to go
the media doesn't call elections uh and
then have all of these low information
letters on twitter be like
tim's so dumb he thinks the media calls
elections
and i'm like every single journalist on
twitter right now is saying
they might call it for biden they might
call this state they did call that state
it's like do you even read twitter they
don't watch the news
they're just like sitting there with no
information and then tweeting like crazy
and this dude messages me and he's like
you really think the media would call it
early
and i was like they heck yeah bro nate
silver is now
calling on fox and ap to uncall arizona
yeah exactly
and the new york times issued a
statement saying oops we thought arizona
was done but edison research got it
wrong it's like man
how long ago is this because i think the
associated press still has arizona
called yeah they do they do
of course and it's 90 reporting and and
it's slowly going towards trump yeah
um georgia now georgia is 99 reporting
but trump's only ahead by like 3 000
votes
crazy north carolina uh
is 94 reporting so we still have a
little more time there but trump's up
there like quite a bit
yeah yeah yeah um and then pennsylvania
ooh pennsylvania trump has about a 64
000 dude vote lead i i've had friends
hit me up
freaking out about trump with the most
ridiculous ridiculous lies you can
imagine like what
well the very fine people hugs for one
mm-hmm i can't believe like you would
support a guy who called nazis good
people and i was like
we're talking earlier but they believe
it and then i get i get a message from a
friend saying like
trump is trying to stop the vote that's
ridiculous it's just because he's
winning now and now if he stops the vote
he'll win and i was like
calm down yeah that is not what's
happening trump wants
poll watchers you can argue his
intentions
if you know what you're talking about
and say you really think he's doing
something fine that's your opinion
the lawsuit was they shouldn't be
counting ballots
until we have watchers uh you know while
they're tabulating because we don't want
any any you know
play yeah if i'll play and they're like
oh but i agree with that
and then i sent i sent my friend the
video where they're boarding up the
windows and she goes what are they doing
and i'm like this is exactly why
trump is saying stop yeah and she's like
but i agree with that i'm like then why
were you mad she didn't know
yeah exactly she didn't know she heard
something on facebook or some some media
and she voted for biden she voted for
biden all the democrats
and i said i said i'm sorry like my
friends from chicago i said
you're gonna have to explain to me how
we all grew up in the same place getting
screwed over by the same people
and you still keep voting for the same
people yep that's horrible no listen how
like one word
could like literally just sway the minds
of millions
trump isn't saying stop the vote he's
saying stop the count
that changes the entire conversation but
the context is what's missing
the context has been stripped away it's
if trump tweeted stop
counting until watchers are making sure
the votes are being counted accurately
and fairly
then people would have been like oh yeah
but the entire msm is saying
that trump is telling people to stop
voting right right and and
and people believe it and there's people
who can't vote anymore
there's these exactly there are these
videos popping up where people are
chanting stop the account and then in
arizona you know count the votes and
they're like
look how dumb trump supporters are and
it's like wow
how do you run a country when these
people just don't
care about civic duty or like
you know what the issue is arrogance
that's it yeah
i don't know everything i'm not saying
you should you should vote for trump i'm
not saying you should be biden
i'm saying there's a lot of people on
the left and that's where the democrats
go
goes after a youth vote because they're
like these people will just do what
they're told to do get some celebrity
like taylor swift and they'll go
go do it they go after low information
voters because they don't got to
convince them of anything
yeah they can just say go do it rock the
vote high five
and that's and that's their path to
victory we've got we got a lot of people
in this country
who are arrogant and thinking they know
how everything should run
like i had a conversation with a friend
someone i've known for a long time
posting all these memes that was just
ridiculous fake news one of them was
like joe biden will
reduce the amount of troops in the
middle east while trump is increasing
them
i'm not kidding and i'm like dude so i
commented i was like hey you know that
trump is actually drawing down our
troops and signing peace agreements
and he was like dude that's not true the
republicans only want war what
and so we have a conversation for quite
a bit and then ultimately i'm just like
bro do you trust me like i read the news
all day every day i'm not lying to you
for no reason
and he was just like i know what i'm
talking about and i'm like i said
okay you know what i'm gonna go there
why do you think you know more than i do
when you work in a warehouse operating a
forklift
and i literally do nothing but read and
comment and report on news all day
and he's like well i read i'm like i
don't care dude
look go believe in flat earth whatever
like you are dead wrong
i can send them articles i'm not reading
your article well there it is
there it is yeah i mean arrogance it's
possible to be very informed
in any occupation but yeah you do read
this stuff constantly or
really up to date on it it's sad but
people have their opinions and they
matter very
very much to them and no i think it's
ego yeah
that's exactly what it is it's ego but
it's the same i mean it comes from the
same place you become attached to your
opinion you see it as part of yourself
and then when information is presented
to you to the contrary you refuse to
believe
it because you see that as an attack on
yourself yeah all i need
is evidence extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence
liar there is no attack on me if donald
trump loses fairly and joe biden walks
in with a handshake and says i'm the
president now i'll say i'm cool you know
there's biting one huh will he say i'm
the president or will he go i i'm the
yeah
i'm the senator of this country now i
mean i gotta i got an honest question
yeah did he just like can you run for
the president and the senate
and the senate
i don't know i mean look at him if you
like and vote for him if not vote for
the other guy tim that's all i can say
no no but it's a serious question like
can you
i think you probably can run i don't
think so
maybe let's double check let's let's ask
twitter maybe you can't because then
like what if you win both
you know you like stuck yeah then they
appoint somebody what if you run for the
senate and the president then become
president and appoint someone to the
senate seat because now it's vacant
i don't think yeah i think probably not
so what if here's here's an idea
what if you ran for president ran for
every senate seat at once got elected
president you just hand picked all the
stuff
that would be an issue no no i don't
think it would happen because you can
only run for
i get it if you live there just kidding
yeah exactly yeah yeah but it would
still be funny but i'm just wondering
like when biden said he was running for
the senate did that like
what if what if trump was trump don't
pick that up he's like he can't read for
sure
the presidency we're suing we're going
to win big leagues no but what if the
supreme court is like
it's true joe biden said he was running
for the senate therefore
and then he goes fight and while we're
using gaffes here's footage of him
saying he created the largest voter
fraud organization on the planet
literally did say that but there's no so
i watched the washington post fact check
on joe biden and
the fraud thing and they're like here's
the real video and they play the clip
and then they play the actual video and
the context doesn't change
i'm like what they just called it a fact
check and then played the full video
where he's talking about
disenfranchisement yeah and then says he
put together a voter fraud organization
and i'm like
okay voter fraud has nothing to do with
disenfranchisement and democrats don't
believe voter fraud is a problem
there's no context that makes it make
sense that joe biden said we've put
together this
the largest and most diverse voter fraud
organization in history or whatever but
to be fair
many of his statements make no sense in
any context i i look i gotta be i'm
really excited for a biden presidency
yeah well this is the thing so i've been
not in a good way like no of course not
i've been torn about this kind of like
in a joker kind of way you know well
people say things like
oh well you know trump is so difficult
to satirize because he's always so funny
on his own but the thing that was great
about the trump presidency wasn't just
satirizing him it was making fun of
everyone's reaction to him
i don't think that we'll get the same
thing with a biden presidency people
don't really have like biden derangement
syndrome no no they don't freak out in
the same way people don't like if
people dislike biden but it's not on the
same level and the entire media isn't
like crying and losing their minds over
his every statement
and he's also not as funny
the john oliver samantha b jordan what's
his face i don't know his name
and peterson who who's the guy
who's the guy who had the netflix one
that failed too i don't know whatever
and
and jim jeffries all of these like
d-list
like knock-off versions of jon stewart
is my conspiracy theory
they were just so annoying and then
finally the powers that be were like
what do we do to get these shows to stop
we need a president they can't make fun
of yep well no joe biden listen think
joe biden's easy to make fun of
when i say that biden but it's sad well
not that's exactly it when i say when i
say trump is funnier than biden i mean
like trump is funnier than biden on
purpose when he tweets something
really savage like oh that's actually
comical but joe biden not so much it's
just
you know why you watch you know why it's
it's okay to make fun of trump
even his supporters orange man no no
it's because it's punching up
because trump is spry boorish
like he's clearly strong and so when you
mock him it's like
he doesn't care like i remember when he
did that rally where he said the lights
that make me look orange and like
everyone laughs
because he's self-aware joe biden is
funny because
he's you know on the way out like he's
his
yeah how do you guys think joe biden is
going to deal with like
black lives matter and antifa oh he's
just going to he's going to walk up to
the meetings and fall asleep and they're
going to sign over power attorney like
do you think that he's the law and order
candidate to stand against
no but is let me tell you i don't know
no
i know she is a cop tim i think no
actually part of me wonders if
the reason that that they uh nominated
her was in some weird way to try to
appeal to law and order
voters but she's a lefty yeah but that's
the thing she's
she's just she's an opportunist she'll
for sure side with blm if that's what
she thinks
i don't advantage i don't think anybody
walked in that
look i think there's probably a tiny
fraction of people maybe one in five or
one in six
who walked into the polling state place
being like wow kamala harris and joe
biden like that's what i want
most people probably walked in and went
orange man bad
and then walked out yeah exactly and
that's why biden like that's why they
might not win the senate well it's funny
because tim and i were having a
conversation earlier where tim was like
you know
the thing is joe biden just isn't
progressive enough for me and i don't
like what they did to bernie sanders and
i really just want far left policies and
i said
you know what kiddo let's wait until
we're not running against the fascist
to have a conversation about whether or
not joe biden was good enough
you did but you didn't pull them off you
took that you took the camera and you
started shoving it in your face
and you're wearing glasses i was wearing
my big glasses big round glasses oh my
gosh
no so uh look i don't know who's gonna
win if uh uh
if joe biden wins it's gonna be it's
gonna be it's gonna be hilarious
not because of joe like i don't know
that's because we
will be funny the only reason i make fun
of chewing on a shop at a pressure
is because he's running for pr the
presidency right exactly i would just
feel bad for him if he wasn't running
for president like
fun of him he's just an old man it's
really sad it's going to be really funny
when our president
it's like mr magoo but like could you
imagine like mr mugu as the president
he like walks up to a wall and goes like
like vladimir putin is like what is he
doing
well here's the thing yeah like if trump
won or wins re-election i could make
four more years of like trump jokes and
tds jokes ripping on the media
if biden wins i'll get like i'll get
like well i'll get like a year tops of
making fun of an old man and then kamala
will be president seriously but we can
make fun of kamala and yeah but she's
not as funny
i wonder if just there's the thing like
joe biden for all of his problems and
and trump for whatever you might just
like about him there they both have this
like likeability thing where when you're
making fun of them it's kind of an
endearing character
but kamala is not no steering in that
way
yeah no she's like she's she's just
gonna start laughing at her and she's
cackling that's the thing like it's it's
actually it's hard to make fun of hold
on hold on what do you what do you think
john oliver is going to do and like
samantha be
if if if i didn't actually see but
that's what these people don't realize
is like trump has been so good for the
economy and jobs
that even leftists hardcore leftists are
able to build
empires and wealth based upon their
hatred on donald trump
and they don't realize that this is
about to go away like even people that
have like crazy merch
like major merch stores yeah the trump's
like
there's so much wealth that has been
accumulated even from hatred towards
trump that people don't realize is about
to go
away it's going to be funny when like
people are still trying to sell the
shirts but
other people are like it's she's just
some guy yeah like i'm not gonna i don't
care man
it's like a picture of trump like you
know getting you know i don't peed on or
something stupid and you're like why
would i want that that's that's weird
when he's the president you're laughing
like hey he's the president
i think all of these it's just going to
be cringe and outdated and it's like you
can't do this anymore you can't say that
but we're still making bush jokes really
late into bush not being president
i saw um i saw it was some seth
macfarlane show i think border town
i saw an episode or two and that came
out in the 2010s in in like
the mid-2010s like when i was in college
and they made a bush joke in it i was
like are you serious like this is still
a dead horse that they're beating
yeah so i feel like they'll still make
trump jokes long after he's no longer
what's gonna what's gonna happen to this
era of comedy
when you know we're 10 20 years down the
line and it's like there's just like a
black
gap in history it's like we had a bunch
of political comedy
you know clever clever points were being
made and then just this dead period of
four years you know where it's you know
just
every job especially with like
everything being pc'ed up like you can't
make any jokes you can't like do
anything that's funny or out of the box
you'll get censored on the internet like
you'll your netflix special
might not be able to make it but it's
just like you can't even have fun
anymore everything is just so npc'd and
like
blank yep like that's all that can exist
right you know
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time